et
un couple quand la brume pour les
malades les saltimbanques de la terre
il ya déjà une année comme un petit gars
re phase à toute trouvée sans vie une
empoché que je n'avais pas mis les pieds
dans cette belle cité mais je vous
dirais qu'une fois et ça c'est qu'on
mardi là mais voguer pyrénées et et où
là où ça n'est pas ça
choquée suketu de la noche au poulet du
mardi gras
et pour les furieux de la fiesta ouais
ouais mais pâtit de madame avec le dit
qu on a le coeur à l'âme comme des vieux
macklowe sentir l'air ça les eaux sur le
bout de ton thiney
les sentir aussi la fin
jusqu'au port du rosmeur et jusqu'au
pendu aux allées à ecouché vos gars se
ranger vos poules jude revient de la
pêche à la mouche la gare mais c'est
l'igas au maximum kouette
metallica ça la chine est et aussi aux
veilleurs de nuit qui ont le guen rue
pour la tordue ouais c'est ça au
hockey venir et à pardonner allait
choquer tout la noche a pris fin
tél
m
à
mais
cette chanson c'est pour la vie
la parade a pas atteint